c'est un nouveau rendez-vous chaque
mercredi nous partons à la découverte
d'une école dans les Yvelines avec vous
régénéralèches vous allez nous parler de
trois is ce soir oui mais juste avant ça
j'aimerais vous poser une question
savez-vous ce que signifie la chronique
3e attention faut pas répondre alors
juste pour repréciser on a accueilli
deux anciens étudiants de troisis
bonsoir avec nous du coup Hélène Le
Floch et Léonard Ahmed
je laisse les autres répondre parce que
moi j'ai la réponse allez institut
internationale de l'image et du son
parfait donc c'est vraiment les trois i
merci mais il faut aussi préciser que
madame est une ancienne étudiante de 3e
effectivement alors du coup donc c'était
colle elle a été créée il y a 35 ans et
on y apprend les métiers du cinéma et de
l'audiovisuel plusieurs filières sont
proposées on a de l'acting du spectacle
vivant des effets spéciaux mais aussi
des jeux vidéo troisième c'est aussi
quatre en France et qui en fait
d'ailleurs le premier campus audiovisuel
d'Europe elle présente également de très
bons chiffres puisque 84% de ces élèves
trouvent un travail moins d'un an après
la sortie de leur diplôme et alors quels
sont les frais de formation régime alors
il faut compter entre 8000 et 9000 € par
an et donc on a la chance aujourd'hui de
recevoir deux anciens élèves
effectivement donc Léonard amet et
Hélène Le Floch bonsoir encore une fois
alors je vais commencer par vous Léonard
donc vous êtes producteur réalisateur et
comédien à quoi ressemble vos journées
ouh là là bah tout ça au moins en même
temps enfin pas tous les jours tous les
jours dans la journée mais en tout cas
ça change beaucoup et c'est ça que que
j'apprécie beaucoup j'en ai même besoin
donc voilà bah ça ressemble à des
tournages ça dépend dans quel côté de la
caméra soit derrière soit devant voilà
c'est juste hyper différent et c'est
super bien vous appréciez
à quoi ressemble vos journées qu'est-ce
que c'est que votre métier puisque vous
êtes régisseuse au cinéma alors là je
suis régie ce cinéma donc sur les
plateaux de fiction série cinéma télé
et moi je m'occupe plus de la partie
logistique donc ça va être organisé tout
ce qui a créé au tournage pas du tout le
côté artistique mais plus voilà la
logistique et sur quel film est-ce que
vous avez déjà travaillé
bah écoutez j'ai travaillé sur les
tuches là j'ai un film qui sort au
cinéma le mois prochain qui va s'appeler
Néné superstar on va en parler tout à
l'heure
aujourd'hui super
et alors justement pour effectuer ces
métiers quels sont les filières qu'on
peut choisir justement dans l'école 3IS
vous êtes passés par quelle filière
exactement
d'assistante mise en scène script donc
pas grand chose à voir a priori avec mon
métier actuel mais ce qui est bien un
troisième c'est que la formation elle
est assez globale assez générale en
première année on touche à tout et c'est
ça que je trouve vraiment intéressant
dans cette école et vous moi du coup
j'ai fait mise en scène donc réalisation
mais mise en scène parce que moi à mon
époque alors je sais pas j'ai pas trop
envie de parler de maintenant on sera
peut-être bouger mais à mon époque on
avait deux spéc réalisations on avait
mis en scène d'un côté une spé plus télé
télévision
moi j'ai fait mise en scène donc voilà
on nous a appris le travail avec les
comédiens on a eu tout de suite ce que
j'adore avec cette école les mains sur
les caméras immédiatement et voilà moi
j'ai fait ça mise en scène et alors
comment est-ce que vous avez intégré
troisis moi personnellement ça s'est
fait je suis allé en fait au
une journée portes ouvertes c'est comme
ça que j'ai découvert en fait l'école
et je l'ai intégré via à l'époque
c'était un concours après les portes
ouvertes et puis après j'ai pu faire ma
spé tranquillement
et je pense que le concours est toujours
accessible enfin c'est toujours sur
concours une partie sur parcoursup je
crois pour certaines formations et
d'autres formations par concours alors
est-ce que vous avez des conseils pour
les étudiants les lycéens qui voudraient
intégrer troisis sur sur ce concours
est-ce que vous avez des petits tips ça
leur donner des petits tips non je veux
dire de soi savoir ce qu'on veut
être créatif
ce truc des portes ouvertes enfin en
tout cas moi ça m'a vraiment servi puis
ça permet aussi de faire un potentiel
comparatif entre les écoles ce qui est
assez intéressant je pense d'ailleurs je
tiens juste à préciser que les
prochaines portes ouvertes sont le 18
février yes et comment pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi cette école
troisième est-ce que vous aviez vu ces
points forts quelles sont ses qualités
justement alors moi c'est vraiment
l'aspect technique est vraiment comme je
disais d'avoir la chance dès le mois je
crois que c'était incroyable dès le
deuxième jour ou même le premier jour on
a fait un truc travaux pratiques tu as
la caméra dans la main et on te dit ok
fait un panoramique enfin tu découvres
c'est les bases mais c'est pas les bases
sur papier et je crois que c'est
vraiment pour ça que j'ai été j'étais
dans cette école
c'est un peu pareil l'aspect technique
il est il est énorme on s'était école
alors je vais pas faire de mauvaises pub
aux autres écoles mais c'est vrai que le
campus à Paris équipé de énormément
d'équipement salle de ciné motion
capture voilà ils ont un parc matériel
qui est très grand pour une école et on
a surtout ce qui est chouette dans cette
école c'est qu'on a la possibilité
d'utiliser tout cet équipement au cours
de la scolarité ce qui est pas donné à
tout le monde lors de sa scolarité et ce
que est-ce que vous avez eu des
difficultés à la sortie de l'école je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de parents qui
ont quand même peur de ce monde du
cinéma de l'audiovisuel et ce qu'il faut
en avoir peur enfin oui effectivement
qu'elle a été votre votre expérience et
quel conseil vous pourriez donner par
rapport à cet univers alors bon je vais
répondre pour mon cas mes parents sont
pas du tout de ce milieu là ils avaient
très peur effectivement à la proche de
la sortie de l'école et contre toute
attente c'est très bien passé pour moi
j'ai aussi le nez un premier stage qui
s'est bien passé après en fait j'ai eu
du travail j'ai encore du travail quoi
ça marche très bien pour moi donc
effectivement la peur de parents elle
est légitime mais je pense que voilà si
on croit en son enfant avec son enfant
est motivé il y a pas de souci là-dessus
clairement clairement moi c'est pareil
pour moi la différence que je j'ai des
parents qui sont dans le milieu j'ai pas
toujours grandi dans le milieu du cinéma
de la télé de la publicité j'ai pas en
comédien mon majeure partie il faut
aussi d'autres trucs mais ils sont
comédiens et du coup j'ai pas eu ce
concept enfin il m'avait quand même
prévenu parce qu'ils connaissent un peu
l'histoire donc il m'avait quand même
prévenu et c'est vrai que moi je voulais
vraiment que être comédien à la base et
c'est aussi pour pouvoir avoir d'autres
cordes à mon arc et pouvoir m'en sortir
après que j'ai fait et de la Real et
après par la force des choses un peu de
production et justement est-ce que les
professeurs vous préparent à cette
insertion professionnelle
oui dans le déjà dans le sens où enfin à
mon sens tu vas dire mais c'est des gens
qui sont dans le secteur qui sont enfin
dans le milieu nous les profs qu'on a eu
c'est des gens qui qui travailler sur
des films à côté il y en a qui ont
travaillé il y en a qui travaillaient
encore sur des films donc oui oui
clairement on a une sorte de préparation
après on a peut-être pas dans ma branche
en tout cas moi je le truc que j'aurais
bien aimé avoir c'est un petit peu plus
de conscience de voilà il faut on
connaissait les bases de l'intermittence
mais connaître je sais pas on nous avait
pas trop parler des différents statuts
dans lesquels on aurait pu découler
après comment ça se passait précisément
peut-être que les producteurs ont eu
plus ça ils connaissent un petit peu
plus les papiers nous un peu moins donc
voilà c'est le seul truc que j'ai un peu
moins eu
Céline vous vouliez réagir oui vous avez
dit que vous aviez touché à la caméra
dans les premiers jours est-ce que vous
avez un petit peu des exemples de cours
de projets que vous avez eu un petit peu
pour donner envie à ceux qui voudraient
rejoindre l'école va vous donner envie
on a une caméra la première chose qu'on
nous dit c'est voilà vous avez un
matériel à 25000 € entre les mains
amusez-vous voilà donc c'est plus c'est
plutôt agréable et après très
concrètement les projets ces premières
années fin de première année en
court-métrage deuxième année une série
fiction donc en quatre épisodes et
tourner en caméra cinéma avec des vrais
caméra cinéma je veux dire ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur un long métrage actuel et
derrière année court-métrage voilà
la plupart du temps voué à être diffusé
dans des festivals donc c'est quand même
assez ça donne envie quoi et vous avez
justement à participer à des festivals
comme le Nikon Film Festival
après coup oui alors les films qu'on
fait en 3e année c'était ça la question
c'est pas trop destiné aux Nikon parce
que c'est assez court le Nikon et les
films troisième année de mémoire c'est
15 minutes enfin après je sais pas ce
qui ça a changé
pas avec nos films de fin d'année voilà
pas avec nos films de fin d'année et
nous notre film de fin d'année n'a pas
eu la chance
beaucoup de festival mais en fait c'est
pas grave
des étudiants qui partent au Festival de
Cannes il me semble oui alors ça c'est
un partenariat avec l'école l'avantage
de l'école aussi c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de partenariats avec les
cérémonies artistiques françaises que ce
soit les Césars Cannes euh qu'est-ce
qu'il y a d'autre les lumières enfin il
y a beaucoup de partenariats c'est ça
qui est assez intéressant dans l'école
c'est qu'on peut vraiment toucher à tout
et on nous donne envie aussi ça c'est
très important dans la troisième
et si je peux me permettre moi j'aurai
une dernière question
quel serait votre meilleur souvenir à 3
is
partager ou chacun son sujet
c'est la cérémonie des Césars je pense
donc j'ai pu réaliser mon film avec une
vraie équipe caméra de cinéma et c'est
une vraie bonne carte de visite et bien
merci beaucoup Hélène et Léonard d'être
venu nous parler de 3e votre ancienne
école en plateau et on vous souhaite
plein de belles choses pour pour votre
avenir professionnel et on le rappelle
les lycéens ont jusqu'au jeudi 9 mars
pour formuler leurs vœux sur la
plateforme parcoursup